welcome to this video round three of the
Norway 2013 super tournament and yeah
let's start right with the first game on
my cover as I did before in the first
two videos of five games and the first
one here swidler against our own leaders
honestly speaking not that interesting
so I'm doing this rather quickly we have
enough English opening here reversed
Sicilian um gasps wheeler playing all
kinds of openings nowadays not only one
year for these are much less predictable
and we got them as mentioned the sort of
reverse dragon this one in fact has some
rather solid way to play for both sides
in fact this dragon set up for white
army is some yet it's quite quite like
the accelerated dragon enter the way it
is in his plate black cannot really go
for a long castles set up as it is usual
in the Yugoslav attack so quite normal
is something like this where black
places his pieces classically in the
center and his son got everything nicely
centralized but it's not easy for black
to UM to find some concrete way to plays
mostly solid in the center and
centralizes so his pieces and what white
is trying to do is maybe go b5 and to
rest the knight on c6 bees happiness own
point that you can attack and there's
also this night to c5 maneuver in the
game we see some of those ideas realized
we are 90 for some very typical way to
play like once to play the c6 means that
Lance the bishop and Dwight this as
mentioned on the way to put some piece
on c5 the night specifically okay like
needs to cover it and this is in fact an
interesting idea with them deformed
white herb breaks in the center
immediately it has got a tactical
justification black um cannot really
take this pawn um I mean it is for
certain cannot take it this way because
Bishop f4 is not very strong it detects
the rook and on a rook move him night
peace happiness in fact very very bad
for like you give the porn back and
white has an enormous position and of
course you cannot go here because this
species a maybe queen d 4 is possible it
also doesn't look too great at hers but
the computer actually believes that like
an can sacrifice an exchange here quite
remarkable you'll get the poem but it's
it's pretty clear that the wrong end is
loved playing for such kind of things
especially considering that black has
got those normal kind of moves where you
just have a decent position it's not
unclear what white is supposed to do
here he's got a nice night on c5 but how
exactly I'm increase the pressure in the
game mum yeah sulit ride with this
playing for be five but black is hallie
a fairly well coordinated so it's
nothing nothing's too special happening
in this position 94 was played and I
think it's very likely that
that creepy 3 was a bit a bit tougher to
defend so here at in this position there
is still a bit of pressure I think I'm
white basically one tempo in this in
this way I mean interesting factors
after King edge aight that on white
really has a good position by means of
the strange-looking move we should be
forces suggested by the computer of
course it looks very young unhuman to me
the smooth but it seems to be strong why
done yeah intends to take and damage the
bone structure and what's really
remarkable is that taking on before
after night five takes before is really
tricky right now threatens to take here
and to take on c6 followed by a five and
in fact this position is not even
defensible for black it's really really
bad I mean it's remarkable how bad this
position is but then it is affected so
it's basically not possible anymore to
defend it just a quick example if you
take here there's some this even maybe
even stronger because night beehive this
Bishop f4 and black a black losses
instantly oh yeah so this is a
remarkable line this should be far as
really a counterintuitive move at least
for human I would never probably never
consider this move only night moves
three four okay but the black should
probably play this anyway and continue
with this position where white is
probably somewhat better but it's not
like black M as in super super big
danger yeah in the game this was played
Dwight still looks nice but maybe it's
not nothing substantial really yeah yeah
this is how I how I proceeded and after
this move a draw us agreed a bit
surprising on to me actually because um
i would think that black still needs to
find some moves it's not super difficult
but then you can you can try for example
here Knight takes no yeah I guess loop
takes and this at the end is ok for
black but it looks a bit shaky I'm
relatively sure I wouldn't have offered
the draw with a five I would have
thought that maybe I can try a bit but
okay i'm a natural optimist and this
villa probably isn't I don't know
probably and says it is a draw but it
was a bit surprised that they actually
agree to this drawing in this position
alright so let's go to to the next game
just need to pull it up here yeah my
camera against cows and certainly the
game of round on paper the world number
one plain black and the yeah fan
favorite nakamura known for his
spectacular style and sometimes question
will behave your own life it's playing
wide okay so no surprise but this is a
surprise now can we are playing the
Vienna it's a very very rare guest at
top level chess is basically never
played and Canton actually surprises
with playing 96 it's a this is not
played that often on the usual responses
Knight f6 the ideas to answer f4 with d5
however in this line nakamura actually
had played a couple of really weird
games think you had played this twice if
i'm not mistaken here played this before
i need to be cautious i added this yeah
exactly this this kind of stuff yeah
this year played in any US Championship
game I think against only shook um it
looks a bit ridiculous but it's a not a
bad line for white it's quite
interesting nothing that black needs to
be afraid of but I know maybe a causal
wanted to avoid this and 196 it's not a
bad move anyway but it's not so popular
and Bishop c4 one drawback of 96 is that
now actually this f4 move is some it's
more interesting because now of course d
5 is not not playable so quickly here
black basically needs to take it and
we'll get them a very Kings gambit like
position where those two nite moves have
been inserted but ok this wasn't my
camera's intention he played Bishop c4
and this in fact also quite often arises
from the from to Bishop c4 the bishops
game okay all normal Knight f6 d3 yeah
and here is a big party of the ways he
black has got various moves the very
reliable move that I usually play here
if I reach this position um I sometimes
do mostly by accident I play something
something else normally and this is also
in my repertoire serious for
like against the Vienna and the bishops
game if you want to look that up my
recommendation there is not f6 you
should see for Bishop c5 this is my
recommendation in the in the video
series the idea being to to play with c6
and d5 so not with the knight on c6 okay
but I'm getting far far away from the
game in the game we had this and yellow
be sure before as a solid move Bishop c5
or smooth but the main movie nowadays is
some night 285 and this is what luck
what cars in played a bit strange to see
the night on the room but okay in the
bishop s worth something like wants to
get the bishop 92 what's actually
interesting is that Townsend doesn't
take on c4 quickly he waits um up to a
point where he really wants to take um
like I'm gonna play F for which I find
slightly surprising i must admit um i
have from seem quite a number of games
in this structure and what I always
considered to be quite ok for widest
move like a for him where you are yeah
in some way threaten to retreat the
bishop and now black girl probably will
take and now this is this kind of
position I have played numerous times
mostly in blitz chess where white goes
b3 Bishop e3 Queen d3 rock t 1 and so on
it's very solid for white and um it's
hard to see or how to imagine how I'm
why does some guy going to be any worse
in this structure he's got nice nice
pieces and blacks bishops are not tell
so dangerous this is what I expect
but the camera went F form and this is
more aggressive but also slightly risky
because after takes if you look at this
you see that the e4 pawn is a weakness
now in the other structure the actually
the pond can go to f3 to support a phone
and now the c-4 pawn is the liability
King edge one getting out of the
diagonal castles and their five this
obviously was the idea that Nakamura
head was the setup it prevents some
blacks normal development and maybe even
prepares some some porn storm I mean
what a very good day you might be able
to play g45 but um here Magnus came up
with them I think very strong reply
played the move on d5 according to wow
wait did this instantly probably had
planned this beforehand yeah b5 is
really a strong move the idea is
revealed after white captures and
there's no real alternative white cannot
really allow like to take or before it's
also threatening so takes and now d 5
this was the idea very strong black
takes over in the center now it's got
very nicely positioned pawns and it gets
somewhat tricky for white now I think he
needs to do this it's not much choice um
if you take on on c6 for example that's
the move d for attacking the light
something like this for example it's
excellent for black you will very likely
I'll get the flop on back there's also
we should be 72 to increase the pressure
on this pawn and then you have two
bishops the space advantage and what
exactly is this light doing so this is
very very good for black I think white
needs to do that and now i think what
nakamura played also is necessary Bishop
to g5 trying to get some pressure on
this pawn and make sure that this paw
information resolves in the center there
should be seven and nine g3 Edison tends
to go to h5 so let's have a look at this
position like Scott the two bishops is
got an excellent porn center but he's
upon down so when my assessment would be
that black is some yeah very comfortable
he's got probably more than enough
compensation but it's not like you can
easily pinpoint on how to how to
increase it let's look at what happened
in the game would be 89 age five yeah
this is of course a good idea get rid of
the night and make sure 11 bishop gets
exchanged yeah enter cards reacted with
evil which is which is strong move if it
has to play deform you didn't want to
play d4 immediately because it
surrenders the whole square now the
night is very nicely placed and like
wants to play this and then play d4 when
this night needs to go on on the side on
some square didn't really want to go to
and now nakamura defense nicely I think
he takes
place night a form move that at first
surprised me a little while I put it on
the edge of the board but ok that's
night c5 as a possibility and there's
also ideas with c3 Queen III and just
block this pawn on d5 and if you look at
the game mango spade Bishop made c3 now
what is a really threatening move like
rook default blocking the pawn and then
it's just an extra point so black cannot
play as slow move like this and maybe
this he can with III with them yeah
black cannot tolerate this idea Queen
III Ruby for so we decided to open up
the position immediately yeah back from
the edge of the board
so the position has simplified quite a
bit and black is still upon down but
okay this is a strong pawn that limits
white and this is potentially very
strong Bishop but black needs to play
energetically and this is what he does
in fact after Queen III attacking a
seven umm qasr plays a very strong move
now a six it's probably not that
difficult to find I mean the pawn was
attacked after all but it's still a very
nice concept because it nicely works
together now if why for example takes
Queen takes less the Sun threat and
after King g1 des route d3 and black has
got enormous activity you will also get
the a to cram and black is probably even
better here maybe objectively only it's
only very slightly but in a practical
game this is some of course very much
preferable to be black if white goes b6
there's rookie form and simply picking
up the pole next with a good good game
for black so la cámara played a for
exchange and now cosplay group III ya
hear my computer recommends queenie five
but i'm not one hundred percent sure
what the big gamma the big differences
what is clear that maybe there is
something but it's not it's not like
completely clear cut how black is going
to improve here that's a bit of her yeah
matter of time if white gets a bit of
time to organize then this isn't so also
dangerous at all
yeah white tries to simplify the
position and it's quite difficult from
black to to avoid that this 95
especially is of course on the idea
Black has no good way to to prevent that
this is the simplification what he could
he played we made this which is an
instant draw maybe this was a bit a bit
more interesting but um it's also
difficult to to consider let's say b6
you need to calculate III and this is
really strong now intending rooty to end
and technology to so Queenie 5 here
probably was still I'm somewhat better
for black very complicated of course
what's clears he played III and this now
is the relatively easy draw takes takes
takes a three k xb to ya and now White
has got those two Paul weaknesses and he
will lose one of them in the game white
even picked up this porn but Quint xr5
secures the draw because the rock is
attacked and move like this leads to
reach to know where it's just repetition
so this is oops yeah this is what was
played and it's working all nicely
together right there now you could've
played this but we cannot he cannot take
here because of that the back rank
yeah in the game after this is exchanged
and I camera played age three and draw
was agreed young maybe instead of this
III move from Queenie five was the last
opportunity to continue to do fight in
this game I think very nice concept a
bipartisan with v5 and and d5 but I
think my camera also defended defended
nicely always have to keep in mind that
my camera's got an absolutely atrocious
score against Carlton he's got like six
or seven losses and never won a game I
mean a classical time control game
obviously he won against him and then
its chest over the board and online but
in a classical time control game cards
and has won numerous times and never
lost the game in fact most of the time
he wasn't I don't think he ever was even
worse it was a very very big clear
performance in the other games alright
so next game let's look at who's first
let's go a rod job off against John
rubicam oh yeah the anti goon thought
White has got a multitude of options now
not having played d for Willem gives him
lots of ideas on her job of place this
this line with g3 YTM has all kinds of
moves Queen a former queen bee three
Quincy to e4 it's really it's huge even
H for us not bad efore yeah okay g3 was
played simply intending to fianchetto
and we now get a position
here after couple of moves we get a
position that is usually reached in the
symmetrical English with c4 c5 being
played early and then this development
the Queen a for this is actually a very
typical move the Queen has some maybe
even intending to switch over here kd3
Bishop h success can be an idea or the
Queen can attack this pawn and the game
quindi 7 was played with over yeah weird
looking move but probably interested in
still okay Quincy for just intending to
take it and black gown black covered
yeah this prevents b5 like a prepares it
again and now wide when to deform so we
basically decided to ignore this b5 idea
p 523 we are up to eight intensifying
the pressure on the center look to you
won and now the queen stepped out of the
D file so let's take stock in this
position um how it is how this position
should be assessed I think um white is
slightly more comfortable is got the
center he's got this before idea but the
most important point is that this Bishop
f4 itm is very annoying this ruckus
exposed and those pawn moves have
weakened numerous square so white can
often play on on this weaknesses on the
queenside also the night a success
slightly slightly off we see that in the
game
wyd managed to to wreck this center now
so we have this typical greenford center
now it was just delayed by a while but
in the process on white managed to set
up his pieces very nicely to support the
center while those two pieces are not
really working together rube t6 and d5
young this now looks looks good for
white he got the bishop am very nice now
see for this is a good idea intending
this if possible and also simply moving
this pawn away from this attack by the
bishop it has a drawback of course this
it just gives away this this pawn but
probably it was some relatively good
chance anyway you need to to activate
your pieces to Queen d70 subtext to yeah
the the bishop and the pawn bishop
deform in fact this seems to be a
slightly on slightly inaccurate the
Bishop to e3 awesome it seems some much
stronger let's examine why if black now
takes on a three what can actually take
b5 there's nothing threatening
so it is not easier to to even make a
move here this corn is of course of
course hanging what's the difference to
the game in the game you played this
move and now black girl could actually
take because if white would take now on
b5 there's this point I should should
make this arrow the queen is skewered on
the on the rugby one yeah so what cannot
take so what is he supposed to do you
played Queen a3 going for a double
attack again and now the Queen retweeted
and yeah if we look at this is sequel
material and what exactly is wide
speaker big advantage here led to a king
to g2 like exchanged and here i think
with loan relatively simple move light
c7 black could have gotten on a pretty
pretty solid position it looks a bit
passive because you are defending
against the deep on but it's very
difficult for y2 to make any headway
here very important is the fact that the
the bishops here on d4 and g7 have been
exchanged if you just the general type
of position if you imagine it with the
bishops on there's always a bishop to a4
move attacking this rook and this is not
possible now this record e6 cannot be
attacked as it is also the case for the
night on c7 so like an basically just
stay in this position and wait what do I
just coming up with it's not easy at all
the computer actually assesses is at
zero zero zero and giving it to give it
is completely equal it really seems that
in this position good job of needed to
to go Bishop e3 to conserve his
advantage ok let's go ahead to the game
the problem is he played this move
didn't play a 927 I understand the idea
of the ideas too let's put a couple of
Hoops to get this set up on so now all
blacks pieces attack the pawn and he's
trying to to win this porn maybe he was
ambitious here trying to try to win the
game I'd say it's possible I mean if you
win the d5 pawn it would be would be
very nice and the problem is that you're
not really able to do it if you just
think about this taking now it's just an
enormous enormous power on the D D file
here cannot take the the pawn yeah
here's an interesting very interesting
position look out for some of course
threatening queen deform winning winning
this book so black is somehow frost
react if you play a slow news let's say
like this that's also a queen move maybe
also Queen III also possible it's very
annoying this rope doesn't have a square
so black needs to sec now in the in the
game he sacrificed on d5 with the serum
in fact here black had a very strong
possibility but it was very difficult to
to spot especially if you consider that
they they didn't have much time that
could have taken here and this is
a difference the difference is that now
here after this that can take with the
Queen and this is a very funny funny
exchange seg-y as this rook now was
supposed to go it's really nice if you
go somewhere here like just grab this
and eaton place on four winds got two
pawns this is a weakness and i don't
really see how black should ever lose it
so he's the only one trying to do at
least an something in the position so
let's go here and now black has got the
very strong idea g5 he intends to play
f6 King g6 and trap this rook the rook
doesn't have any squares it's really
funny in a practical game I would easily
prefer black here maybe it's really
better and so it's quite a funny
position you also cannot go here of
course because this of course white can
get out of this this is chucking
possibility but it's still a trap truck
how do you ever get it out here go here
just king here and it's trapped just a
funny funny situation um I'm not sure I
think black is more comfortable here
however he took with this rook and now
you don't get the Queen trade in here
this was the problem and now in this
position black cannot avoid that that
more pieces I exchange and this is
really a just lost yeah getting out of
the diagonal yeah and now why does try
to to realize his extra exchange can go
rookie five attacking the b5 call yeah
here's another weakness combining this
idea and this idea and this is not
defensible yeah yeah quite nice
threatening Queen g7 mate yeah and after
this black has no check so it's really
made next move with the Queen g7 made
yeah this position black handsome is
truly a golden opportunity with the
other exchange sec but this is really
something that you can easily tell
afterwards with three minutes on the
clock for eight moves it's not easy at
all to spot that ya hear this rook is in
this troublesome spot is tricky maybe
white even needs to go here and through
k 3 is dubious don't know but this was a
very good opportunity for John lat ve em
together on a good a good game at the
end but he was in huge trouble before so
a bit of a game of missed opportunities
at the end road job of was was
converting his extra exchange and this
means that Hamas on 0 points out of
three games so this is
becoming a bit of a nightmare of course
them he was the big outside of before so
before the tournament he certainly was
aware that he would probably lose a
number of games but starting with 0
points as is obviously bad truth ok next
game let's check what the world champion
did amount against Apollo we have a
Sicilian night off it's good to see on
no princess alien once in a while
instead of the Bishop b5 and c3 and
various slow Sicilians ok we got an
English attack characterized by this f3
and g4 set up yeah this position has
been played I don't know numerous times
talk you talking about hundreds of games
um it's a it's quite funny though some
things that are connected to this game
let me call it my notes on ya need my
notes yet cannot do this for memory b5
preparing the typical card to play rook
g1 supports this 96 now this this takes
them the a foursquare under control so
before would actually force the light
back on some very unfortunate square
this is why night 85 is played the idea
is that 96 is a serious idea move like
this is answered by 96 this is the the
point
gap and now like as in trouble something
like this is just a bottom yeah black
needs to cover the square some whoopsie
a desert it's a good move g5 right h5
King to be one yeah I now some some fun
facts about about this for years ago
this position was reached in the game on
mount against Falcon in Nice France and
this is probably one one of those melody
amber tournaments those combined rapid
and blindfold tournaments that have been
organized for a number of years
unfortunately they don't exist anymore
as the main sponsor as has stopped to do
that um yeah so are not had this on the
borders white before and kayaking played
to the myth g6 in this position yeah so
your usefulness covering the night
preparing giving some some air for the
king and maybe at some point you can put
the bishop there the poor thing is into
there's a right game bye-bye Vichy and
so to pull off with some justification
maybe could have expected this to happen
he played Knight to f4 however I mean in
this position you played Knight to f4
yeah what's the idea of this move on and
replies with a three yeah of course you
always need to check the capture
now this looks good at first sight but
then if you look at look at look at it a
bit deeper than you recognize them
that's night before it's a is really a
problem you will get this and white gets
completely destroyed yeah I cannot
cannot take it you can take on air
format you I mean the first time you
cannot do this move you need to play
something else but in fact Alan didn't
capture it only played a 3 which is just
a good move it stops before give some
some room here for okay of course at the
moment and it's covered but it's simply
an all-around useful move to to play g6
and now the second fun fact in this
position the move Queen c7 was played in
yeah and in fact just a couple of month
ago in January in bike the traditional
why can't see tournament and it was
played in the game leg hole with white
against a lot so aren't has played this
as black before so it's one of those
curious main lines that player some tend
to play with both sides so it's um just
a good nicely balanced dynamic position
that you can play with both sides okay
to pile of plate the g6 which is sort of
a mixture of ideas it's a typical move
age 42 to cover the pawn of course if
black girl would have would have taken
this you need to to check it there's
this possibility
this will say so but now aged phone it's
just a good supporting move Queen c7 and
now we're at the point where white needs
to learn to choose how to how to
continue I don't know decides on a very
concrete concrete way to play and I
think it's probably a good one because
it leads to a position type way you can
hardly news but where you can certainly
try for more he took on a phone and now
played night to d5 if you look at this
um at first you recognize that there's
always this pressure on c2 but it's
nothing nothing serious after this and
this white can actually take on d5 this
is just the check black doesn't have any
serious attack here so everything's
nicely covered so black gap of course
doesn't take on c2 but takes on a five
and what is this position now in fact
this type of positions um comes up
relatively frequently in this in this
variation on white is temporarily upon
down he very often gets the ax for porn
back and white has very nicely
centralized Queen on d5 and the bishop
will get a very good position on d3
where it covers the weakness on c2 and
not a weakness but c2 is a point where a
black of course likes to attack on the C
file and the bishop on callousness
nicely in addition white has got this
attacking ideas it's not easy to do to
checkmate length of course with the
bishop here that can also go to g7 later
um first of all the light is going to
get the the bomb Meg yep I think this is
just a slightly better position for
white it's not dramatic probably but
given the choice I think everybody would
would choose to play wide got this d5
pawn to to attack and it's not so clear
what blankets doing he activated his
Queen which is a good move actually see
3 p-8 Quincy to ok now on Queen g3 was
played it is important to note that
Queen trades and films to do that this
is really very one-sided in the long run
after f4 and Bishop g2 this pawn will
will fall and the problem is that those
queenside pawns are a really weak um it
would be slightly different if those
pawns word on a six and be fine but this
kind of setup looks are very
advantageous for white also because the
king is is near the pawns oops is so I
can unlock draw 0 is near the pawns can
sometimes in a way down there on the
queenside so black guys shouldn't really
trade queens now he didn't he played
this well Queen g3 and now f4 yeah I
think here exactly here to follow makes
a mistake but it's a it's not easy at
all i think it's very simple afterwards
to to go quickly through those games and
switch on a computer that can give you
rather
on rather good evaluation of opposition
sometimes they saw make mistakes but
usually they simply m tell you the the
right moves he played the bishop to d6
but he actually should have taken age
for it looks really risky and I can
understand that he didn't do that the
problem is Queenie to attacking the
bishop so black girl needs to react to
this from the cupboard and then after
Queen f3 yeah you can count the number
of squares this Queen as it's not much
but black has got the the good move h5
and this seems to make sure that it's
it's an okay position white of course is
not in any danger you can always take
defy for example this is probably what
black should have done he played Bishop
b6 and this has a huge drawback the
problem is look at this Bishop g2 Bishop
f4 this was the idea we should define
API now we've got this Bishop takes f7
check idea and black gown needs to react
to that King g7 and now Queen to b4 this
is very strong it's such a nice
centralization also attacking this this
Bishop and black now has a really hard
time to to defend this position it's
probably a it's probably over already I
don't think that you can save this
against them against best play it's also
such a dominating bishop if you look at
this especially of course towards the
King side yeah queen three plate and now
I'm very strong just retreating the
queen but intending moves like group 1 2
D 3 and this really shows that those two
pieces are we are very tied up there and
in some very unlucky men are defending
f7 now I'm played through 12 d3 he had a
very strong alternative actually with
Queen f1 attacking the bishop the
problem is that there's also this idea
and if black goes here this wins a
rather easily Queen f1 was it was even
stronger but this is strong enough them
it's not it's not in doubt that why this
is very much better Queenie 5 he also
could have tried to enter White's camp
even law with Queen f2 but there's
Queenie for a very powerful
centralization attacking the bishop
getting this idea into into play if the
bishop would move away from covering the
five square and this is in fact very
good for white probably winning if you
look at this yeah note that this isn't
is a subway because at the end to d5
yeah you should be saying oh press the
wrong button here flip it okay what I
wanted so wanted to show this if black
plays this yeah we had to be at this
this line yeah but this is strong again
attacking this very nice point again now
the queen is attacked the rook is
attacked and the Queen has no square
where can still attack the two look so
it's just an extra exchange or black
needs to sacrifice the linea which
should be winning relatively easily for
wyd he's got this potential porn
baseball yeah in the game he played the
Queen 25 Queen a free attacking bishop
h2 yeah now I'm white as more than one
strong move but this was what strong
that's a it's a funny idea if black
takes on d4 there's Queen f7 so what is
black supposed to do there's all kinds
of stuff hanging look d7 hanging and and
so on it's um it's ugly lost he played
the Queen e7 work 24 taking the Queen
and black now sacrifice the Queen
there's no way to to move it to look at
this yeah okay course not flute here
this is a bit stronger and checkmate
okay so in the game you sacrifice the
the Queen and terms just a matter of
relatively simple technique ya hear
black resigned it's not possible anymore
to keep this power long in any way keep
this position together it's not clear
what Becca's i'm going to play here you
move the the bishop there's Queen f7
cannot move the the rook or this rogue I
it's just it's just lost enter the pile
of he resigned and very nice victory by
bhavishya think he went for a position
which is simply quite one-sided and like
as a hard time to have a do something
don't we have something active
then T'Pol of it seems misjudged this
move Bishop to d6 but it's it's
difficult to play you've got this Queen
bit cut off and you have a position
where a small misstep can easily cost
you the game and very quickly yeah nice
swing prominent um okay only one game
left and this is kayaking against one
how kayaking won the first two games so
he's offered the great start and now
he's got Dwight and with her ground
let's see what happens yeah and we got
this line of the Sicilian which is
sometimes called the the classical
variation it doesn't have such a
clear-cut name that's usually called the
classical this was a very popular in the
1990s crumlin played it very often as
black he was a very successful and good
to the cilium player before he switched
to the more solid openings with one in
five for the match against guisborough
um of course this opening for black um
allow us to were two different systems
white can play this Bishop c4 move this
is the the souls in variation which was
course the favorite of bobby fischer's
or Bishop g5 the the Richter rouser and
this is nowadays the most get the most
common booth 622 itm there's a multitude
of possible lines this in fact what
wrong how plate was very popular in the
90s especially exactly this this
variation and it has fallen out of
fashion on in recent years simply
because it is believed that black does
not have so good counter plane and maybe
a big specialist
would disagree but this is only what I
know about the line we see that here why
does advance in the center and uses this
this pin the the fun thing is that like
can just play here because white isn't
threatening really because this Bishop
is hanging with check so black has got
this tactical idea to make sure that
he's not losing material yeah white now
retreats night hanks now note that the
bishop attacks the light and the queen
of course could see five takes things
yeah and this was exactly the position
that has been discussed numerous times
in the 1990s and I always believed that
the theoretical conclusion was that
white is enjoying a very one-sided type
of edge here got two bishops he's got
this idea putting a bishop on d6 and
he's got three against two which in a
possible end came can be a substantial
asset if we look at the game rupee 196
oh all looks normal if you ask me yeah
we should be four okay this provokes be
three but it's not a terrible move
anyway Quincy five attacking the serve
this column okay if you look at this
position I felt black now would retreat
you let's say here yeah how to assess
this position I think it's pretty easy
right is just substantially better with
the two bishops and and a very nice um
endgame inside you just need to get
the Queen's and it will be a very
one-sided affair I don't really
understand why wrong how went for this
line I mean this the rouser in general
is certainly playable of like but this
line was always as far as i know this
reputation of being somewhat passive and
and uninspiring of course this kind of
position on black and try to defend and
maybe hold but why go for that it's
simply not attractive to play and in the
game however in this position now one
how played the roof rook to deform yeah
okay note that the bishop is is hanging
and he's playing rook deform counter
taking the Queen here kayaking had a
very strong possibility but this is one
of those moves that the computer points
out to you and you think okay this is
easy I would have done that but it's not
so easy thanks um here he could have one
really won the game with Queen f2 the
ideas to pin this this rook the bishop
is still attacked and the the fun point
is that for example after you create
this is Bishop see one move so roof do
you want isn't a check anymore and this
now is simply deadly from like look at
this you can retreat the bishop and
white will just simply improve his
position with let's say here intending
this or intending to pin again and this
is over cannot defend this position f6
this is an idea like a like this but
what also has this idea it's not bad at
all the Queen has no way
to keep the Rope defended so you need to
give up the exchange and you have zero
compensation a general problem of this
structure and regardless of the fact
that group t4s blundering the game way
that this this night has his no squares
it's simply dominated by the pawns and
also the bishop is not great you can put
it on c6 but it's very often just
pointing into thin air yeah ok this is
what kayaking played well as mentioned
this was probably winning but it's not
like like easy to see if black eye drops
back there's this move you can also
easily overlooked that idea and blankets
again just losing yeah I played Bishop
e3 which in fact after this leads to an
end game that is also a bit of a torture
for black three against two for possible
passed pawn and the bishop am the only
slight drawback of whites position is
the pawn on e5 butcher's bit isolated
but if you imagine and a bishop on d6 is
no problem it's covered so in the game
in fact it went downhill really quickly
this look is also in a spot of very
young exchange it I'm sorry and now it's
it's just difficult the pawns are coming
frankly speaking I think against a good
technical player it is it is almost lost
now he played some pseudo active moves
on the King seiffert infected just
weekends
white pushes the pawns there's not much
black can do about that so why it's idea
is simply to to create a passed pawn in
the long run like it's basically upon
down because of this backward phone he
in fact tried to to advance it but after
taking p.m. yeah after this he realized
that there's rookie 52 h 5 and it's not
there's nothing to do against that lack
of course cannot take here because of
rook f1 winning the bishop so there's
simply no defense to Ruby 5 h 5 yeah
very convincing win by kayak and he
could have gone this we've done this
Queen F to move which even wins a
quicker but it's very computer register
smooth what he did was perfectly okay
for human so kayak in three on three
starting with one hundred percent great
great start and yet Noah already gets a
bit tricky for causal to try to to win
on this home turf is already 11 and a
half points behind he played three
drawers and dumb this is some this is
getting a difficult probably he needs to
work I a keen to have any sort of chance
I'm not sure I don't have it in front of
me now when they play with round in
which color but yeah 303 is a great
start for the young yeah now is Russian
he switched Federation's couple of years
ago for the silh young russian you feel
like his um yes this is around forever
but it's the very young only 23 years
old maybe maybe only 22 i'm not sure is
the the same
one in the same years cars in 1990 yeah
thanks for watching this video very nice
and fighting round again three wins just
as some runs before and we have got more
decisive games then then draws in this
tournament yeah i'll be back come with
further coverage for Round four um I'm
not sure if it is on Saturday actually
they have two rest days I think yeah
well okay the the round whatever the
date is tomorrow long on saturday or
sunday i'll come around for as well yeah
let's talk then bye